something i was able to do at that time
because it wasn't in that part of the
state
but once i returned i started yes and
it's still something i do now
um i don't think they've been doing it
out lately because of coven
they tried it over the phone and it
wasn't as successful but i'm still on
there
on their list to volunteer without you
know disclosing any
clients or anything specific can you
just
tell me a little bit about the type of
work you're doing for that organization
sure i'm i'm mostly
writing letters to particular parties
letting
those parties know about the
income levels and liabilities and assets
of various parties
you know there's certainly this is pro
bono work you're doing correct
there's certainly a lot of opportunities
to do pro bono work
in you know the legal community in
minnesota you've chosen this particular
group and something that you've
continued with
so if you could tell me a little bit
about why
you find this work important
i very much enjoyed my experience when i
was there in
in law school and
i gained a lot of knowledge at the firm
i was at
prior to the firm i'm at now and i
actually can use that direct knowledge
to help the people that used to be on
the other side of what i was doing
and oftentimes it's very
simple information or something that's
very basic to an attorney
or even just some basic life pointers
that might not be obvious to other
people
and you can give them this information
even in a 20-minute
time span and you can make a world of
difference for them and some of them are
just
so thankful for your time that it's
that's why i keep doing it
well thank you for continuing in that
work i
appreciate it i i'd like to follow up
on another response that that you gave
on your questionnaire and you were asked
about the statement minneapolis police
officers
are more likely to respond with force
when confronting black suspects than
when dealing with white suspects
then in your response you said that you
somewhat disagreed with that statement
and i'd just like to hear your thoughts
on that and in the basis for saying this
sure
i believe i put somewhat disagree
because i wouldn't say i'm
neutral on it but i also don't think i
have enough
information on it to actually be able to
say
in the affirmative that yes they
definitely respond with more force
so in that respect i feel like i have to
disagree because i don't have
information that says
yes they would but being neutral and it
also doesn't feel like
a correct response so that's why i would
somewhat disagree
and it was uh the question was specific
to minneapolis police officers and so
maybe i should ask you a little bit
about your
your baseline and what if any experience
you've had
direct observations you've had of
minneapolis police officers
um not many um
maybe i've gotten a ticket or two so
that would be a
really minor interactions minor
infractions
sure um but other than that i would say
most of my interactions with any
police officer or sheriff it's mostly
been confined to
um the courtroom for the most part i had
i don't think i've ever
actually witnessed someone really
getting
arrested or you know anything like that
that i go i've seen xyz happen
and here's what i'm feeling about it or
here's what i
i really haven't so it sounds
and i'm going to restate this if i'm
putting incorrect words in your mouth
please do correct me i think you will
but it sounds like you're reading the
question and you're not going to
speculate about something that you don't
have direct knowledge of and so
you said somewhat disagree because you
couldn't say
affirmatively that you think that that's
true
correct okay
so uh i'd like to make the
the question well let me follow up on
question the the last of that series of
questions
and you were asked if how you felt about
the statement the criminal justice
system
is biased against racial and ethnic
minorities
and you responded that you somewhat
disagree with that statement
and so i'd like you to as best you can
just in your own words
you know just talk about that issue and
how you came to that conclusion
i would put it in the same category of
how i responded
to the last question about physical
force that
i don't have enough information on it to
be able to affirmatively say
yes and here's why
um so that's why i said somewhat
disagree
um so let me ask a slightly different
way if somebody made the affirmative
statement
um that the criminal justice system is
biased against blacks and other
minorities
and said that they had a basis for
saying that would you have a
factual basis to dispute it would you
argue with them say no it isn't
and this is why i i don't have those
facts so no i would not be able to
okay
uh you indicated a thought in the
initial
questioning that you may possibly be
familiar with or have contact with
somebody at the state ag's office
correct um just saying that you know i
have
past classmates people that i've
previously worked with that i know
some people at one point or another have
gone to the ages office and left or
so i i can't state that i don't know
anybody there
okay but i wouldn't be able to say i
know these five people there and we go
out to lunch every day
it's it's not to that extent or that you
know anyone who has said
you know in and among the other duties
uh that i have at the ag's office i'm
working on this particular case
okay
you indicated that your general
impression of the defendant is neutral
and you stated that
you believe that you would need to learn
or know more
about police protocols to form a true
opinion
can you please explain what exactly you
were getting at with that answer sure
i feel like a lot of people
are jumping to a conclusion
based on feeling and gut reaction
and this is what i would do
but the vast majority of people who are
saying that are not police officers
and i'm not a police officer and
i don't know what police protocol is i
don't know what is a correct hole i
don't know what's an incorrect hole they
don't know if
you know this is what you normally do
and this one you should never do i
i don't know and i
i can't form like an opinion that i'm
gonna put on paper under perjury
saying here's how i
feel about him negatively or positively
until i know the rest of the information
and i don't know that information
so as a lawyer you're looking at this
you're looking at this document
taking it pretty seriously yes that's
understandable
all right may i have a moment your honor
okay
thank you and uh one more follow-up
there was a question that was put to you
people today do not give our law
enforcement officers the respect they
deserve
and you indicated that you somewhat
agree with that statement
can you share with us a little bit about
you know
what you're basing that opinion on sure
i think that at least i'd say in the
last
let's say a couple years
so many people have been focusing on
negative cases negative aspects of
police work that we're often
not really looking at the positive and
the positive thing that
things that police officers do for
society or even just something as simple
as
you know if i'm in court and i need
someone removed that there's somebody
there who will do it
and it's in many ways a thankless job
especially
in the last couple years that i i don't
think it's always
um given the respect and think that it
should if there was a if there was a
problem here in court you would
rely on and expect the law enforcement
officers to intervene
right correct and i've had i've had to
rely on that before
so it's it is nice yeah um
it sounds like you have a deep respect
for law enforcement is that fair
i would say so okay
the question i have then is you know
given that
deep respect and the thought that
sometimes officers
don't get the respect that they deserve
from the rest of society
would it be difficult for you to
judge the credibility of the testimony
of a police officer
in the same manner that you would judge
the credibility
of the testimony of another witness say
a bystander on the street
no i i believe credibility comes down to
every single witness
that it's not um because the witness is
a police officer that they're more
credible than anyone else and i would
put
um there are a lot of jobs that don't
get a lot of respect just the same as if
a teacher were on trial i think teachers
aren't getting the respect that they
deserve and if a teacher is on trial but
you know you can still judge a teacher
for doing something
that other people say they don't agree
with but
in general there still might be a a
great profession but no i
i would say credibility of anybody comes
down to the witness it doesn't matter
what your profession is or lack of
education
it's it's what you saw how you remember
it
things like that all right well thank
you very much i appreciate your answers
here today
but your honor the state will strike 29.
excuse you from this jury and so there's
no other jury duty that's related to
this term so
just if you get us uh summons in the
future feel free to answer or please
answer
uh the way out the deputy will escort
you and take your paperwork
yep yep but i know exactly what you're
going to talk about
uh let's hold off in the next the next
is a group advisory in any case
it's a group advisory to begin with but
there
we want to talk a little bit first okay
that jury has left
mr nelson i think we're talking about
the same thing everybody
check their email it appears that the
supreme court has denied
review of the defendant's petition for
review of the court of appeals opinion
i think we'll look we can talk about
this tomorrow morning at 8 a.m
and it's a fact i think we still have
the jurisdictional issue with the court
of appeals
um so with that
um everybody want to take a few moments
if it's short you can absorb it pretty
quickly but
let's go for let's go get the next group
my intent
uh is to go through the group process
and keep one and turn the rest loose for
tomorrow
because i think we can get through one
but i doubt much more so
mr schafer if you would
you
um
you
[Music]
[Music]
okay you can take just about any seat
you'd like
and be seated thank you
all right well good afternoon members of
the jury panel
first of all can you all hear me because
if not if you're having trouble
understanding me
we could get you hearing assistance
devices okay
my name is pete cahill and i'm one of
the judges of the district court
and you have been summoned as potential
jurors
in the case of state of minnesota versus
derek chovin
which is a criminal case related to the
death of george floyd
on may 25 2020 a person charged with a
crime has a right to a fair trial
before an impartial judge and an
impartial jury
in order to make sure that the jurors
who are selected are impartial
the law provides that the court and the
attorneys for the parties may ask
questions to all prospective jurors
which must be answered under oath
first thank you for filling out the
questionnaire and that was mailed to you
your contribution the important and
serious matter at hand
is best served by your continuing to
provide
full and complete answers to the
questions that you'll be asked today
these questions will follow up on issues
from the questionnaire and possibly
other topics
after the questioning is over the
attorneys will have the right to excuse
some of you from service on this jury
and i may excuse others of you for what
is called cause
in either case it does not mean that you
are not a fair person
and you should not take offense in being
excused
i also ask that you not take any offense
at any question you may be asked
we must pry to some extent in order to
explore opinions you might hold
and hear about experiences that you have
had that might affect your ability to
serve in this
case the defendant mr chauvin has been
charged with murder in the second degree
and manslaughter in the second degree in
the normal course of trials charges may
be added to or subtracted
from those charges but those are the
charges as it stands today
now to those charges the defendant has
entered a plea of not guilty
which is a denial of each and every
material allegation in the charges
and i'm now going to ask the
participants in the case to introduce
themselves and their clients
so that you can tell me whether or not
you recognize anyone for the state
thank you good afternoon my name is
steve slicher appearing on behalf of the
state of minnesota
good afternoon my name is christina
marinakis and i'm assisting with the
prosecution
hello keith ellison with the state thank
you
i'm joshua arsenault with the state
thank you hey mr nelson if you can
introduce yourself and your client
good afternoon my name is eric nelson
this is my client derek shelvin
my assistant amy voss and thank you
anybody on the panel recognize anybody
who has introduced themselves
okay no hands uh
other than maybe perhaps on the news or
anything like that
are you acquainted let me put it that's
a better way are you acquainted with
anybody who is
uh introduced themselves all right
does anybody on the panel have uh anyone
they know uh there are other attorneys
who might be making an appearance
for the state matthew frank
aaron eldridge jerry blackwell
and other people who work for the office
of the attorney general
anybody know anybody who works in that
office recognize any of those names
okay and your juror number 31 31
who you recognize
okay have you had are you an attorney
former attorney uh
as a retired before you retired did you
have cases with
against mr blackwell okay
but you're familiar with him and did you
work professionally with him
okay but you recognize the name okay
thank you uh the fact that you recognize
his name is that going to cause any
concern here
no okay all right anybody else who knows
somebody in the attorney general's
office
okay anybody know anybody who works for
mr nelson's firm
that you're aware of okay
you have been given a list of potential
witnesses
i'd like you to look that over if you
have not done so already
but when you come in for individual
questioning uh
we're going to ask you if you know
anyone on that list and again for the
same reason do you know him would it
affect your ability to be a juror
now one of the things that the attorneys
may not do
during jury selection is to instruct you
on the law
but i do want you to be aware of some of
the basic concepts that apply in all
criminal cases
so that you may keep them in mind as you
answer the courts and the attorney's
questions so i will instruct you as
follows
first the charges against the defendant
are not evidence and they create no
inference of guilt
no member of the jury should in any way
permit himself or herself
to be prejudiced against the defendant
because a charge has been made against
him
or because he has been placed on trial
the defendant is presumed innocent of
the charges made against him
and in order for you to find the
defendant guilty the state must prove
guilt
beyond a reasonable doubt the defendant
does not have to prove his innocence
the presumption of innocence remains
with the defendant throughout the trial
unless and until he has been proven
guilty beyond a reasonable doubt
according to the law and the evidence
admitted at trial
proof beyond a reasonable doubt is such
proof as ordinarily prudent men and
women would act upon in their most
important affairs
a reasonable doubt is a doubt based upon
reason and common sense
it does not mean a fanciful or
capricious doubt
nor does it mean beyond all possibility
of doubt
now if you serve on this jury you and
your fellow jurors will be the sole
judges of whether a witness is to be
believed
and of the weight to be given a
witness's testimony there are no hard
and fast rules to guide you in this
respect
in determining believability and weight
of testimony
jurors may take into consideration the
witnesses interest or lack of interest
in the outcome of the case
the relationships to the parties ability
and opportunity
to know remember and state the facts
manner age and experience
frankness and sincerity or the lack
thereof
the reasonableness or the
unreasonableness of their testimony
in light of all the other evidence in
the case and any other factors that bear
unbelievability
and weight if on this jury you should
rely on the last analysis
upon your own experience good judgment
and common sense
there are things you should not do
during jury selection
you are not investigators you are not to
go out to do any looking
you're not to ask people about this
matter you're not to use the internet to
look for information about the case
or about the law and above all you must
not talk to anyone who is involved the
lawyers or the witnesses
do not be offended if the attorneys
parties or witnesses do not speak to you
they know that it would be improper to
contact you except through the normal
selection process
and they will confine themselves to a
brief greeting
during the selection process your family
and friends will be curious as to what
you are doing
you may tell them you are you are on a
panel of potential jurors in a criminal
case
and that is all you should tell them
since that is all you should tell family
and friends that is all you should tell
the general public
so during these proceedings please
refrain from using
facebook twitter or and other social
media
to announce that you are a potential
juror or to comment
on this trial you may access
those social media tools but please do
not publish any information about this
case
or your thoughts about this case you do
not have to stay away from people and
refuse to speak to them do whatever you
wish but do not talk about the case
and above all do not talk at all to
anyone involved in it
now because of the nature of the charges
this case is receiving media coverage
do not read about this case in the
newspapers or online
and do not listen to news about it on
radio or television
now this trial including jury selection
is being televised
but no video of you or any other juror
will be taken at any time now or during
trial if you are selected
also your name will not be used in the
courtroom you will
only be referred to by your random
number to protect your privacy
the audio of anything you say during
jury selection will be broadcast
unless we need to discuss something that
is deeply personal
or extremely sensitive or embarrassing
or might very clearly reveal your
identity
in those cases i will specifically order
that the audio not be broadcast
in that case you will still have to
answer questions it will still be on the
record
but it will be without any audio being
broadcast outside
the courtroom
and with that
[Music]
first of all i appreciate your patience
in waiting as we go through this process
and with the exception of juror number
30
i'm going to release the rest of you
till tomorrow uh to come back at nine
o'clock
we're trying to adjust the number of
people we bring in based on how quickly
or slowly we're going
and it varies and so it's not a perfect
science
but i think i'm fairly confident that we
can get through
uh 31 36 37 and 38 tomorrow morning
and so please return
try and be here by 8 30 so that we can
start right at nine o'clock
and possibly a little earlier we will be
in session at eight o'clock uh dealing
with other matters
uh but we hope to get to you at least by
nine o'clock if not a little before so
if you could be here by 8 30 that would
be greatly appreciated so with that
again advice don't read about the case
and we'll see you tomorrow morning
except for number 30 who can
stay behind and we'll direct you to the
appropriate witness chair
thank you and you can go with the deputy
okay
and your jury number 30 i assume come on
up
right here on the witness chair right
next to me
and i realized somebody left their mask
there you can just
if you would like leave it or toss it
aside um
we have plexiglass between us and i'm
going to continue to wear my mask
however it might be easier for everyone
to hear and for you to speak
during the selection process if you take
your mask off but if you prefer to keep
it on you may certainly do so i leave
free to keep it on but if there are any
issues with
intelligibility let me know so far so
good
it's actually doing pretty well i would
ask you to pull up to the microphone a
little bit
we can't unfortunately move the
microphone very much it's pretty hard
wired in place
um but yeah feel free to keep it on
while we go through this process
um before i turn it over the attorneys
there are a couple things we need to do
first of all
i'm going to swear you in so that all
your answers are under oath so if you
could raise your right hand
do you swear or affirm under penalty of
perjury that you will truthfully answer
all
questions about your qualifications to
serve as a juror
thank you all right thank you uh before
i turn over the attorneys i'm going to
ask this question
uh you filled out a questionnaire and
thank you for doing so
um that was quite a while ago
but can you verify that everything on
that questionnaire was true
yes and are there any changes or
additions because
you filled it out you know quite a while
ago and
in the interim you might realize you
left out some information or something
your opinions haven't have evolved a bit
so if there's anything like that
that you can think of right now not to
my knowledge but
okay the attorneys will go through the
question a little more in detail
and so something might come up that's
different from what's in
your questionnaire don't worry that it
may appear different or
additional that's certainly
understandable given the dynamics of the
situation
uh the questionnaire did advise you not
to
read any articles or pay attention to
any media
about the case and i assume you've done
that but we also recognize that in the
months since you filled it out
you might inadvertently come across
information a headline
um maybe
a friend talks to you and shares some
information that you weren't aware of
before
now you already indicated what you knew
about the case at the time you filled
out your questionnaire
and that was good we expect that most
people
uh have heard something about it and so
we appreciate knowing what it is you
heard to the best of your ability
uh but is there anything in that interim
space that you've learned
yeah uh the only things that i've
learned um was just by
being around in life that there may have
been a juror selected
over the last couple of days um
and then i personally was concerned for
the live streaming element of this so i
did look at the live stream yesterday
for a couple of minutes
just to see if witnesses
or your potential jurors could be seen
um
yeah well and we prefer you don't do
that
yeah but uh what did you what did you
get from that
short experience i i've learned nothing
new about the case and i've tried to
refrain from
reading any articles about any facts
related to the case
um and i have just you know
heard while listening to the news of the
date
of the case or something like that yeah
and
when you went to see how it looks here
were you satisfied with
that your identity was being
sufficiently protected
yes all right and we even do that to the
extent of if there's something in your
questionnaire
uh for example if you say you're the
head coach of the timberwolves it's not
too hard to figure out who you are
by the way he's not on the bus but it's
that type of thing where
if it is so unique that people would be
able to identify you
we might have to talk about it but we
would do so by shutting off the audio
um i don't recall anything in your
questionnaire that would fall into that
but
uh just knowing all that does that give
you comfort and
yes in answering questions yes all right
and as far as the physical layout of the
courtroom and the covert restrictions
we've put in place
you're fine with all that yes okay
so uh part of the thing with the
questionnaire is not to say that we can
we only want people who've never heard
of the case i think that would be
uh hard to do and that's not the legal
standard either what we're looking for
are people who can
tell us what they know but then put that
aside
and they may form opinions everybody who
has
been exposed to this case probably has
certain opinions about the case
or about the people involved but again
got to put those aside as a jury you
decide this case only on the evidence
that you hear in court
and applying the law as i give it to you
and not follow your own standards
you think you could do that yes okay
now do you recognize any witnesses on
the long list of you
no i do not uh all right then we we
see did we do that i think you may have
answered something about the length of
the trial
you have any problem with the length of
the trial that we have here
uh i i've seen the prospect of the
length of the trial and
as with anyone it will impact
it's going to be four weeks starting
march 29th okay is our best guess
okay and so the lawyers will probably
follow up on that
as you sit here right now is there
anything that would absolutely prohibit
you from doing that
no all right anything else you would
have a question about before i turn over
the attorneys
mr nelson on if you could inquire as the
juror number 30.
good afternoon sir hello
so before i begin my questioning i'm
just going to again introduce myself my
name is eric nelson
i represent mr shelvin i'm going to ask
you a series of kind of general
questions and after that i'll go in and
follow up with some questions
about your responses to the
questionnaire are you okay with that
yes so but before i do that i just kind
of want to ask you
about um so you logged in on to the live
stream yesterday
yes yeah i was uncertain of the
process of being seen or unseen
um and that was about
that was about it okay and and i
appreciate the concern i guess i just
want to know how long did you listen i
listened
for two times for approximately two
minutes
okay and were they um
were they were jurors being questioned
or were were there discussion of legal
issues
uh jurors being questioned and i
saw one one or two questions from you
and that was
all that i saw during that time okay so
one or two questions
um that i was asking of a potential or
prospective juror
okay yes okay
um just a reminder we do need to use yes
and no rather than
the colloquial mm-hmms yes
stuff like that yes thank you all right
um so you and i meet at a party or some
social gathering
what are a few things you want me to
know about you
um i love music i love to
uh yeah
i largely uh do music i love musical
theater
um and i love to
meet new people and interact with people
okay
and um born and raised in minnesota
wisconsin until uh age
24 something like that yeah and then
moved over to minnesota and then moved
over
to minnesota okay and um
what was your initial reaction when you
got the jury summons
uh a bit of shock
but i
tried to just take it in and say
i'll be present in the moment and deal
with it when the time comes
um did you receive notice of your jury
service at the same time you received
the questionnaire to fill out
um no i believe i received one and then
okay so if if you if you can try to
remember back to that point when you get
the first letter that says
you have jury duty in march of 2021
your initial reaction was kind of shock
yeah yeah it's uh something different in
the mailbox
okay and um then you subsequently got
a packet with the questionnaire and
instructions on how to fill that out and
return it back right yes
and um you learned that you would be a
potential juror in this case right
yes and how did you feel when you
learned that information
it is a difficult case
with a lot of attention on it
so i took it with even more weight
that it is an opportunity to
serve and it's also a heavy burden
on anyone involved in the case i i am
just going to ask you to
it's not the muffle i think it's just
the oh sure
there we go much better yes so could you
just repeat that i'm sorry
um i i said i believe i said that it was
uh given the national
attention that it's even more
of an important civic duty um
if if discerned for me to serve or not
to serve
okay did you have concerns about your
physical safety
if you were to be selected um
no i don't think so did you have
concerns
about any sort of safety surrounding
being a member of this juror
no um yeah coming here was
it felt a little weird but yeah tell me
about that what do you mean by it felt a
little weird coming here
um well there's a heightened level of
security
around the area and uh
puts someone a little bit on at ease but
that's
uh that's all yeah okay
when you saw the level of security did
it make you feel a little better or was
it more just sort of a shock
to tears um it was
i think it just heightened the
level of just trying to be present here
and trying to
listen and discern and hear um
what you and others will ask me
okay
now can you think of a situation in your
life where you have been called upon to
resolve
a dispute or a conflict between two
people
yes i believe so can you just give me a
you know again without identifying any
people or places just a general sense of
what that
dispute was like
trying to trying to pick one but um
i would say
miss speaking and
raising uh
that's interesting to think about times
that you're evolving to your life
so my apologies it's okay
i would i would bring up um a time where
i
stayed longer socializing with
friends and introducing my wife to
multiple people where she's more of an
introvert
and not realizing that her
comfortability
was where mine was at
and then later realizing that she felt a
little uncomfortable
and uh discussing with her
and learning you know that she felt like
it was time to go time to you know
just take some time uh and
not be introduced to as many people as i
had planned okay um and so that was a
like a dispute
involving you and your wife sure right
um what about a situation however where
you're not directly involved in the
dispute
but you're asked to resolve the dispute
between two
other people yeah um
with covert it's hard to think of when
you're sure
let's make it more general sure in a
situation
and again just from your life experience
you don't have to give me any details
about the incident but
how how do you resolve a dispute
between two people what tools do you
bring that analysis
what do you think is important in order
to help two people resolve a dispute
to help two people resolve to dispute
it's
important to meet where they both are
and to hear both sides of what they're
discerning and discussing um
and to try to find some common ground if
need be
or if possible um
and to try to form
um
try to have some compassion for one
another and understanding and
discernment of one another
okay um and again and i just wanted to
verify
um that i remembered enough about you
that from
your questionnaire and it without
referencing where
it's my understanding you work in a
church right that is correct
and you have a position within a church
of leadership right
yes and um is it a would you describe it
as a larger congregation or a smaller
congregation
it is in between a couple hundred people
and with covid
and with starting that position um
in late 2019 i probably haven't even met
most of the members of the country or
some of the members of the congregation
okay so you you haven't had a uh
well in that context you're a leader in
a leadership position in a
church and there's a congregation and
congregants will have disputes with each
other
great yes okay and
um in that context
so what you're saying as i understand is
you want to try to meet them where
they're at try to
encourage communication between the two
and
exhibit compassion towards both sides
right
and i think that's all wonderful and
admirable
right but we're humans and human
conflict sometimes
um requires more to resolve
agreed agreed so
if you were in that predicament where
you have two of your
parishioners who are um
in dispute how do you
how do you solve that right i mean
how do you what are the steps and tools
you take beyond
the the kind of the general approach
does that make sense to you sure yeah it
it very much depends upon the severity
of of what's going on things that
sometimes
happen in churches would be
you know there's there's an issue with
what happened with the sound for example
hopefully i'm being heard
and clear with diction as i speak into
the microphone
um and sometimes
it would fall on uh
someone that it was not going well and
as
a leader i would want to step in and try
to help
take um some of the pressure off
of the person who was responsible for
the mistake
and to try to implement better training
or try to help them out um instead of
taking sides and saying oh yeah that was
on them
they they shouldn't have they should
have messed up the audio that day or
something like that
or for a specific song choice there's
um people have very
very different preferences when it comes
to music or something like that
so our preferences need to be considered
and taken into mind
and if it's appropriate um to meet
the one side with yeah we'll throw in
him
the next week and try to reflect
some of
what you're feeling of tradition or what
you know what makes you feel comfortable
then that is easy to meet them there
okay and in that context have you ever
been
involved with you know two parishioners
or
congregants um where
one person is saying situation a
happened right this happened
and another person who was a participant
in that very same event said that's not
what happened
this is what happened right how do you
reconcile or how do you resolve that
conflict
and then also you tell which person is
being more
truthful about the circumstance i would
uh talk to both of them individually
and then i would see if there were
other people at the specific situation
that occurred
and hear them out as well possibly
discern or talk with
other leaders of the church whether it
be volunteers or staff
to decide where to go from there
communicate with my my boss or my pastor
in this case yeah
okay um and so you're a part of a
staff of a a larger staff right
i'm part of the staff of the church of a
mid-sized church
which is you know of a few staff
okay and so you does within
that context do you make group decisions
on how to best
implement the plan or absolutely yeah
and how do you feel that you work within
that group context
um it depends upon what
is being addressed we all have our our
different areas where we lead and
discern
uh what is best for the group and
um as a member of a church
the pastor is generally the leader um
so they make the final say and
we work within that
structure so if i understand you you
would say there are certain
circumstances
based on your area of expertise where
you may be more of a leader
yes and other circumstances within a
group where
it's less of your expertise so you're
going to be more
of a follower yes okay so this is
obviously you know these questions are
kind of geared around
this is a group decision making process
right you understand that that's what a
jury is
yes and there is no one leader
right do you understand that correct and
all 12
jurors if you were to be on this jury
would have to agree unanimously
do you understand that yes um
if you held a particular position
about some piece of evidence in this
case right
and you felt it was important but other
members
of the jury had a completely different
perspective on that same piece of
information
how do you reconcile that in the group
context
sure um
well first off i would hear them out i
would listen to them
before speaking and then
i would reflect personally on what was
addressed
and talk with the other jurors and try
to come
to a solution together um i
understand that there will be moments in
this
in this case where there will be
opinions that
contradict each other and go against
each other
and i would i would be a group worker
that would try to work best
with the group to come to some sort of
conclusion
and i guess you know along those lines
if you were to um be so convinced that
this piece of information
was the key right this whatever this may
be this is the key
there are other people who disagree with
you
would you simply abandon your position
in the in the name of building consensus
i i don't think i can say that with
with um certainty based on not knowing
that situation uh i
am one to work and mediate with people
that that is for certain um
and if i believed so strongly
in something i would be
[Music]
discussing that with other people for
a while okay
so you wouldn't just abandon your
convictions
without further um
evidence to the contrary would that be
fair to say
correct i i certainly would listen and
hear out the other side in any situation
um as i want to be someone who is
is fair and
yeah i i if there's something very
strongly that i
believed i would continue to discuss it
further so i want to ask you some
follow-up questions on your
questionnaire
and i recognize that you filled this out
a few months ago
and that you don't have a copy of it i'm
presuming
and i'm not trying to trick you i'm not
trying to convince you
you know or anything i just want to ask
you some follow-ups
and if you want me to read things i will
do so all right
and so
the first question in the questionnaire
asks you to kind of reflect upon what
you had
seen or heard or knew about this case
do you remember that yes and you wrote a
sizable paragraph based on what you had
heard about this case right
yeah everything i could think of at the
time
right um
and i i want you to know that you it's
okay for you to have
opinions about this case and it's okay
for you to have strong opinions about
this case
ultimately your role as a juror is to
decide the case
based on the evidence that's presented
in this courtroom
not on those opinions and not on what
you may have heard
months ago agreed agreed can you do that
yes okay now
so we're going to ask i'm going to ask
you some questions about some of the
opinions that you had formed
and some of the words that you used to
describe those opinions
fair enough yes okay
so the one of the questions asks
from what you have seen read or heard do
you have a general impression of the
defendant
and then it gave you some boxes to check
in let's say very negative somewhat
negative
neutral somewhat positive or positive
very positive
so kind of a spectrum right and you
check the box very negative do you
remember that
sure yes and when they asked when the
questioner asks why do you feel that way
you wrote despite calls for help of i
can't breathe from floyd
it seems derek murdered floyd and the
others saw or assisted the chokehold
which resulted in death
do you remember writing that yes okay so
it's fair to say that you formed an
opinion based on what you had seen in
the
the news or conversations from other
people or social media
yes that was very bad yes
and of course i do not know derek
and i uh did not watch
the video which i'm sure we will cover
um
and uh as a juror or a prospective juror
i would have to refrain to what is
discussed and discerned in this
courtroom
and i under and i understand that and
that's where we're going to kind of talk
about some of those
those things so but you made some
interesting word choices in your answer
that i want to have
to explore with you if that's okay yep
you said it seemed derek murdered floyd
right yes um and
that was the opinion that you had of my
client
at the time you wrote this correct
correct and so
you're familiar because the
questionnaire also asks you about things
like the presumption of innocence
and proof beyond a reasonable doubt
you remember those questions yes
my question for you is knowing that
there's this legal principle of the
presumption of innocence
and you've already formed an opinion
that my client
murdered mr floyd can you
set aside that opinion
apply the presumption of innocence and
listen to this case
yes i can
and you also uh in this same paragraph
reference a
choke hold which resulted in death right
now one of the issues that we'll
ultimately have to decide is what was
the cause of death
can you set aside your previous opinion
that it was a chokehold that resulted in
death
and listen to the evidence in this case
yes if discerned that i was
an appropriate juror for this case it
would
i would try to be as clean of the slate
as possible
and that's ultimately what we need to
ask because
at the time that you um
are if you were to be called on this
juror you have to actually be able to
say
i can do it right not i can try or i
think i can
i need you to to be able to say i can do
it
and it's it's clear from some of your
responses
that you have some pretty strong and
what we can talk through some of these
but some pretty strong
positions in terms of social justice
issues
in terms of racial issues in terms of
policing within this country
right all of those opinions
they matter to you right and you hold
them dear
agreed i i
yes but in this
case we're asking you to say
none of that matters yes
can you confidently say you can do that
yes
you've discussed this case with some
friends and family members
correct yes before
yes understood before you filled this
out since that time you've not told
anyone else that you're here or
talked about this case right no correct
and what you talked about were things
such as the need for police reform
through
making or providing alternative methods
of response like social workers or other
community resources
to better fit calls to 9-1-1 and help
make police officers
jobs less or job tasks less diverse
and offer some other resources
so you have a pretty strong position
that
people who call 9-1-1 maybe the police
should not have to respond to all of
these calls
yes i i believe that what is asked of
our
our police officers is is
immense um and they
in general do a very good job of serving
our community and it'd be great if there
were
help for a friend uh who is
you know a friend who is discerning
whether or not to commit suicide
if they would be able to receive or
call a number for a social worker
helpline
[Music]
yeah okay so um you are
i believe you said you somewhat agreed
with the concept of
of defunding the minneapolis police
department i
i have listened to that um
that idea and i believe that there
should be additional steps taken
to provide those
social workers supports that would help
all people feel better and feel like
they
have more resources to
to respond to in an emergency way
and in fact according to your
questionnaire you've actually
financially supported efforts for police
reform right
correct does that mean you've um donated
money to various organizations
yes i've donated money um to
organizations that advocate for
listening
um to diverse voices and perspectives
and to form policy opinions on that
okay and you you also indicate that
you've written some letters to elected
officials
in support of those same notions right
yes
with respect to your perspective on
race and justice in this country you've
also taken
as i understand a fairly strong position
in that regard right
yes um one of the questions
asks you whether blacks and other
minorities do not receive equal
treatment as whites in the criminal
justice system
and you strongly agreed with that notion
right yes um can you just expand and
tell me what do you mean by that
how what why do you strongly agree with
that statement
i strongly agree with that because there
have been uh there's been research done
for example with african-american people
and the use of marijuana i believe they
are
three times more likely to be arrested
for
the use of marijuana compared to their
white peers
[Music]
and that there are certain instances
that
happen within a traffic stop
where it's more likely to escalate with
diverse people with officers
than with their white counterparts okay
and you also indicated that you believe
that the criminal justice system or you
strongly agree i should say with the
statement
that the criminal justice system is
biased against racial and ethnic
minorities
yes i do uh believe that and
it's an implicit bias it's one that
sometimes
i don't even recognize um that i
may be biased towards someone else
um without even realizing it well and
that that raises an interesting
i guess counterpoint because the
questionnaire asks you
to agree or disagree with the following
statement
i do not trust the police and you
strongly excuse me you somewhat agreed
with that proposition
so do you have a personal experience
with the police that causes you to
mistrust police officers
no i i've had
in general a great experience with
the the police and um
my my perspective largely comes from
seeing other incidents where people of
color have been
poorly treated by the police
and so your mistrust of the police is
within the context of
racial issues
yes
there's a question that says because law
enforcement officers have such dangerous
jobs it is not right to second-guess
decisions they make while on duty
and you strongly disagreed with that
concept
i believe we all should be held
accountable
for our our actions uh that we do
in our daily life and uh
that goes for the police as well
okay and so and i'm
i guess i want to ask can you think of a
situation
unique to a police officer where
an officer has to make a very fast
decision
and he may be wrong
yep okay and
i'm not suggesting that you shouldn't
second-guess it or look into it
but is that understandable
yes we're all followable people
we can all make mistakes
now you were asked a series of questions
about
the both the black lives matter
organization or movement
as well as the blue lives matter
organization or movement
and you are very favorable of the black
lives or you think very favorably of
black
lives matter and very unfavorably of
blue lives matter
that's do you remember checking those
boxes yes
and in the context of your answer
regarding the black lives matter
movement you are in favor of defunding
traditional models of police
some some traditional novels of policing
yes
and um the blue lives matter
you state that it was well intentioned
but misguided
correct our police officers are
our uh service
members that are just they impact our
lives and help
by and large and it's misguided when it
comes to
the verbiage of blue lives matter
when placed in context of history i
believe
and i i mean i what you wrote was the
movement
is unintentionally apparent
parenthetical for the most part
racist as it takes the black lives
matter cause
and adopts it seeing
correct yeah
you also indicate that you are members
of certain
organizations including certain members
of
or certain organizations that advocate
for
racial justice right correct
you also had some uh there were some
questions about criminal justice the
criminal justice system
and the question was do you believe our
criminal justice system works why or why
not
and you stated that you believed it's in
disrepair largely because of laws that
focused
on crimes committed by poorer people
i don't believe jail should be as
unduly used for non-violent crimes
correct
so again i just i kind of want to circle
back
and it's sir it's okay you know
i'm not i'm not challenging your beliefs
right i'm not questioning your right to
believe what you believe
and i'm not neces i'm not disagreeing
with you in many contexts
but what i what i have to be certain of
i don't know what's in your heart only
you do right i
i have to trust what you're telling us
everything that you've answered in terms
of
all of these questions are really
focused on
[Music]
racial justice defunding the police
a mistrust of police because of racial
issues
organizations that advocate for
defunding the police you've contributed
financially to these organizations
you have very unfavorable views of this
instance incident right
you've formed very strong opinions right
and so your whole being right
your whole being is being
put on the question here right and
despite all of those beliefs despite all
of those
deeply held convictions you think you
can just set that aside
and be a fair and impartial juror in
this case
i believe if you and uh
anyone uh if the court came to that
discernment that i was
uh the prop a proper juror for this
trial
doesn't it feel kind of like walking
into the lion's den in a sense for you
i think for most anyone that's walked
into this
they'd be lying if they didn't say that
yeah
so again i just have to i have to know
there's a difference between i think i
can
and i can right
do you think you can do it or can you do
it
i can be a fair juror who who
puts his uh a
perspective only within the bounds of
this courtroom
thank you sir thank you you're under me
i have a moment
whatever
sure 30. i'm going to ask you
the question kind of a follow-up to
where we're at on this fair and
impartial
um and you gave a very
honest and to be honest differential
kind of if we think
you can be fair and partial then you
will uh
but it's kind of a little bit be putting
the onus on us to make the decision if
you can be fair and impartial
and ultimately we will but we need to
know
because only you know yourself well
enough
to say that i can be fair and impartial
i know myself
i know what i know i know what my
opinions are but i know my duty
if i'm a juror is be fair and impartial
and
based on certain topics some jurors
very honest they say you know i don't
think i can
high likelihood i would try i've never
met a juror who didn't say they would
try to be fair
um and and if you could tell me i not
only could try
and we're just asking you from your
knowledge of yourself
do you think you could you be fair and
impartial
i can be fair and impartial all right
thank you
mr nelson all right the defense is going
to excuse you mr
juror 30. and so uh you're free to go
about your business uh
if you get a summons in the future come
back for jury service but this
does complete your jury service for this
child okay all right thank you
thank you for your answers to the
questions and filling out the
questionnaire thank you
and the deputy will take some paperwork
all right
just the right amount of time we've run
out of jurors
uh we have the uh
petition for review being denied to talk
about tomorrow because we still have
pending
the court of appeals uh regarding
staying jurisdiction or whether i have
jurisdiction to continue jury selection
excuse me or not and so we have to also
talk about that and how it
plays in to the two
and i believe we i'm gonna bring in five
jurors for tomorrow morning and four in
the afternoon that seems to be more
uh shooting more accurately for not
keeping people waiting
uh inappropriately so
[Music]
anything else that we need to go over
for the record
uh after you've had a chance to talk
could you send the court the numbers of
the motions that we're going to deal
with tomorrow in addition
to the pending appellate litigation
all right and i think i have for
tomorrow numbers
31 36 37 38 39
for the morning and 40 41 42 and 43. is
that correct mr schaefer
okay just so we know that all right
eight o'clock tomorrow we'll renew
motions thank you we're in recess
you